こんにちは、はじめしゃちょーです。だいぶ前の動画でハンドスピナーを千個
使って動画を撮ったと思うんですけど…結局
使い道がなかった…ん〜でっ⤴︎
千個今一応持ってきてるんですけども、あれ以上なんかどうしようも
することがないので。今回ですね等々力陸上競技場
にきておりまして、川崎フロンターレさんの試合があるんですけども
ファンの方が結構多いので
この人の多いタイミングでハンドスピナー千個を
ちょっと頑張って配り切ろうと思います
というわけで今回は
何分っ…間の間でハンドスピナー千個配りきれるか検証してみようと思いまs〜〜
では
ぴー
↑ぴー
♫
はじめ「よしっ」
はじめ「え"ー皆さま、ハンドスピナー無料で配っております」
はじめ「ハンドスピナー欲しい人！きてくださぁい」
たくみ「きてくださぁい」
はじめ「いる？」
はじめ「はいはい、どうぞどうぞ」
はじめ「ハンドスピナーどうぞどうぞ」
はじめ「あ＆％＊＄＠」
はじめ「もらったら…もらったら行ってくださいね」
はじめ「はい」
はじめ「どうぞぉ！無料で↑ぇす」
はじめ「急に来なくなったよ〜！」
はじめ「ハンドスピナーただですよ！」
はじめ「まだもらってない方！」
たくみ「はぁ⤴︎い、どうぞどうぞ」
少年「黒と緑くださぁ↑い」
たくみ「黒と緑が欲しい？黒と緑か、はいどうぞ」
はじめ「あー 、すみません、どうもありがとうございます！ありがとうございます。」
♫
はじめ「いる？いる？」
はじめ「みんな動画回さず、ハンドスピナー回せよ！」
はじめ「あと五個ですよぉ！」
はじめ「ラスト！！」
？？「は↑い、はい」
たくみ「はい、どうぞ」
たくみ「どうぞ」
はじめ「ラスト三つ！」
はじめ「ラスト二つ！」
たくみ「あと一個」
はじめ「あ"い、ラスト！」
子供「あっ、はい！はい！」
はじめ「はい」
はじめ「しゅうぅりょぉぉう」
ＢＧＭ「テケテケテケテケテ」
ＢＧＭ「テ－レレレレ－レ－」
ＢＧＭ「テレレレ－レレレ↑レ－レ↓」
ＢＧＭ「テレレレ－レ↑－レレ↓レロレロレロ－－」
ＢＧＭ「テテ↑テテ↑ケﾃﾞﾃﾞﾃﾃﾞﾝｯ(迫真)」
はじめ「しゅうぅりょぉぉう」
たくみ「イェーー！」
一同拍手
？？「イェーイ」
はじめ「はい、じゃぁ皆さんフロンターレさんの応援の方頑張ってください」
？？「あえー」
はじめ「バイバーイ」
はじめ「てっしゅー↑う」
はじめ「うぉっし」
？？「わはははwww 」
はじめ「はい、というわけで、えっとタイムの方がですね…
ハンドスピナー千個本気で配ると
17分ちょうどぐらいです」
はじめ「17分くらいで配り終わりました」
たくみ「お疲れ様です」
はじめ「まぁちょっとハンドスピナーより動画を回す方が多かったですけど」
たくみ「多かっt」
はじめ「少しでもハンドスピナーを回して、フロンターレさんの応援をしてくれれば、うれっ…ちいと思います」
はじめ「バイバイっ！」
たくみ「じゃっ！」